i thought you did such a great job
with this role and i'm i'm sure this has
to be a very tough day for you everyone
coming in saying you did great
it's been one of the hardest days of my
life stephen thank you for acknowledging
that i'm just kidding
exactly um no but i i have a lot of
things i want to talk to you about but i
i've been asking everyone the same first
two questions
uh recently and you know when i'm
talking to people
so i'm going to start with what movie
have you seen the most
oh man what movie have i seen
um interestingly enough
can i say three movies
is absolutely one of them um
carmen jones is another one and clueless
still written great by the way i watched
it not too long ago a few months ago and
guess what that script
still holds up and also
paul rudd still has an age today
[Laughter]
no um if you could guest star on any tv
show
what would it be oh wow that was very
fast
i am obsessed with law and order and the
beauty of law and order is it's always
on
there's a number of law and orders
aren't there yeah you watch the whole
there's a victim's unit mariska on me
come on you know what i mean
i completely understand i definitely
want to be a victim it's like
i wasn't expecting that but yeah that
would be yeah um
so jumping into jumping into why i
actually get to talk to you um
first of all congrats on the golden
globe nominations uh
that's that's fanta that's fantastic but
um the thing about billie holiday
i think is that she does not get enough
credit for being
very early on in terms of civil rights
because even today musicians
a lot of musicians are like afraid to
speak out about certain issues
but in the late 30s she sang strange
fruit and was really a pioneer in this
can you sort of talk about that yeah
absolutely i mean i think you know it's
interesting now you know especially with
that sort of cancer culture the way it
is
people get scared to sort of talk about
politics and they don't want to lose
you know maybe fans on one side or the
other which i understand we're going to
need because we are
i understand we sort of reflect the
times but back then that woman was
actually worried about dying every time
you know
that's like tell people i was like i
don't know what it's like to get on
stage
and to say if i sing rise up tonight
this could be my last night reading
honestly
and that's real you know what i mean
that's she was so strong that was sort
of something running in the background
but
you know billie holiday would sing
strange fruit and leave the club and the
cops would it would be a
full-fledged high-speed chase with them
shooting into her car
that happened a few times you know so
it's like we gotta remember like
her life was on the line and ultimately
she gave it up for you know she died of
cirrhosis of the liver but they wanted
her to die the whole goal was to
as hoover was amazing at his hands and
it was amazing
exploiting whatever we think someone had
and using that too
as he would say give her enough rope to
hang herself you know
so i think that was one of my big
incentives in doing this movie was that
the world would finally be able to
um say thank you to her and recognize
her as and i wouldn't even just say
she was an early civil rights leader i
would argue that she's a part of the
genesis
of the civil rights as we know it now
because it was you know we hear of the
death of emmett till that really set
everything off which it did but the part
that's erased is that it was
billie holiday singing strange fruit in
defiance of the government
that reinvigorated through the marshall
in the movement and so i think it's
you know we really owe her a debt of
gratitude and the fact that her legacy
they were trying to get rid of her
memory period but they couldn't because
she was too famous
but where they did succeed and where
they often succeed is the narrative war
and so if we can change the narrative to
her just being tragic
drug addicted junky you know problematic
troubled you know issues with men you
know
then we've succeeded and in that regard
they did succeed so it's it's amazing
that the song has survived and is in the
hall of fame now but she really was
a great the godmother of civil rights i
say
i um i agree especially doing a lot more
research
on uh you know um but this had to have
been
you know you're not you've never done a
movie like this
and never had to do a role i mean this
is a
daunting challenge for any actor to take
on this role
when lee eventually said i want you to
do this
were you like i mean internally were you
like can i do this
because this is going to be a challenge
yeah i mean
internally i was like i can't do this
so i was like you really probably gonna
have to find somebody else because i'm
not
i mean from the beginning you know it's
funny i always say leah and i
probably bonded on that first meeting
because neither of us thought we should
be there
he was like i don't want her to be the
one to play billie holiday she's not an
actress
i was like bro i don't want to do this
i'm not an actress so
no thanks and i love billy holiday it
was like
in my mind i had this nightmare that i
would be just a giant
stain you know what i mean like just a
stain on billy holliday's legacy a stain
on diana ross's incredible
interpretation and legacy
a stain on audra mcdonald on broadway
like
so i i was when we first went in i was
like no no
no no no definitely and he was not
feeling it either
but then we just connected you know and
i and we we
you know we saw each other and we saw
our insecurities and our shared fear
and you know and um and
and then i saw his need to tell her
story often authentically and
i still didn't think i was a person to
do it but i agreed to meet with the
acting coach that he connected me with
which was tasha smith great acting
coaching director
and and of course i read the spirit by
susan olivia parks
they also introduced me to tom jones my
the dialect coach
uh my dialect coach and um and so i'm
going through the audition process but
even going through the audition process
i'm like nah
nah like
[Laughter]
so i will tell you even the day and it
was like literally the day after the
oscars
the top of 2018 that he called to say
you got the role and my family was
sitting there like whoa this is crazy
and my initial reaction was are you sure
you looked around because i just feel
like this is not a good idea and i don't
wanna
you know he was like will you just shut
the hell up and be prepared on set when
we get there
um so it was definitely labored it was a
lot of prayer and peace that had to go
into it for me and for him as well we
had to kind of just link arms and
dive into this together and sort of
overcome our fears
of about what it could be as opposed to
what
you know what we you know think we're
supposed to do here you know what i mean
so it was
yeah it was definitely like a leap of
faith for sure
lee has um crafted some really great
performances
um what is it about him that gets
actors to sort of deliver these great
performances
you know i think well first of all a i
think
authenticity you didn't mean really
really not just like
for the characters for his actors he has
a desire for these
people to be human for them to jump off
the page for them
to be real for them to be relatable you
know in ways that might surprise us you
know what i mean like one of the things
he told me that someone had mentioned to
him that the
language sounded very modern but
everything that we grabbed
came from interviews that we heard her
speaking where we heard lester speaking
where we heard so i think people forget
how much our cool
popular language now came from lester
young or came from like billie holiday
or
you know or um monk or mingus you know
or
coltrane or you know so it's like we we
forget that they kind of were
a little bit the birth of cool you know
what i'm saying so um i think he
humanizes people in such a beautiful way
where you can empathize with them uh you
can be mad at them you can have a
relationship with them you know what i
mean the way you would
um and i also feel like he has a great
love and a great respect for actors you
know and i think
it's beautiful on set he does not just
look at his actors as just like these
parrots you know what i mean are just
actors
to him we are artists you know what i
mean as well so
he he would go into a scene he would
sometimes know specifically what you
want and then sometimes you go into
scenes like i don't know what's the best
what do you guys feel like is the best
thing to happen here what do you
so it was wonderfully collaborative
a lot of integrity you know just treated
his actors as
creators as co-creators with him so it
created a real
just kind of like as he says like a real
cookout kind of vibe you know what i
mean on set so it was
you know again he has a great respect
for what it is that we we do and what we
give
give in space you know uh i believe
that you had i could be wrong about this
about 55 different wardrobe changes
oh yes and i think a lot of them were
made by prada
and i'm just and i'm just curious
hypothetically i know you wouldn't
actually steal anything from set
i did i stole lots of things and i have
no shame about it
i was going to say hypothetically what
did you borrow from set
i did i borrowed a fur coat it's vintage
um i did borrow you know uh
one of the lingerie and the sets
they've actually gifted me multiple
things since then which have made me
feel really guilty about stealing it
but let's just be very clear no one was
unaware that i was totally siphoning off
the wardrobe
everywhere i was like they're like
borrowed they're like yeah where'd the
coat go like we know where the code is
it's in andrew's closet at home like
but um uh no i mean if i could have
if i could have gotten it into my bag i
would have gotten that beautiful prada
gown at the end
dancing sequence with the purple
feathers on it
i would have borrowed
the black um velvet dress where she's
like creating the macabre look and she's
putting the shoe polish in her hair
um just because it made my boobs look so
big and honestly i don't have no movies
but uh but they did actually gift me the
coat which was
huge for me like it was so emotional for
my birthday recently which was so
special
um they gifted me billy holliday's
famous coat that they actually made a
perfect replica of with the wider
sleeves she would wear it all the time
which was a part of her activism
because they would write articles just
sort of shaming her for
being a black woman wearing a fur coat
like it's she is she's embarrassing you
know why would she wear diamonds why
would she wear fur so
they gifted me that and it has a ld
embroidered into it so it makes me feel
special because it's like ld for lady
day and then also ld for lee daniels so
they just recently did that so i might
get back those other pieces maybe
thank you for sharing that uh you
borrowed uh i am curious
obviously you can't pick when you're
gonna film certain things
during the making of a movie but did you
try
or did you talk to lee about hey i'd
like to film this later in the shoot
because i think i'll be ready for
example
when you wanted to film uh singing
strange fruit
or you know stuff like that because i'm
sure there were things you didn't want
to do on the first day of filming
yeah and then we did it all on the first
day of
[Laughter]
that first week of filming oh my gosh
it was like so crazy so i didn't
actually ask that or request that
because i didn't know it was the thing
to be honest with you i was so
laserful i was terrified i mean every
single day i was like today's the day
i'll be terrible and they don't fire me
so i was like so i didn't really know
that that was a thing or i didn't really
you know i wasn't thinking about it i
was just like
just be prepared i combed through every
single thing i memorized every
word and tried to memorize as much as i
could as we would get rewrites and
different things on set so
i mean my plate was so full with that
and i think i just sort of kept my focus
on making sure that i was prepared every
single day you know
and then making sure i had some
open-ended things so that i could
receive whatever change of direction or
so i i didn't really i didn't have a
preference of shooting because i didn't
i didn't know i have no frame of
reference i had no experience and
so um and i don't know if it's even
something maybe i would do it in
another scenario but i i didn't have i
was so focused on like
let me just not suck today so
that was that was so no i didn't do that
but yeah it was
you know singing strange fruit that
first week was definitely challenging
um and challenging is such an
understatement it was so
painful and transformative and then
triumphant and it was
and then urgent such a sense of urgency
you know i mean so it was
um but yeah no i didn't there was no
as far as timeline goes i was like y'all
deal with that i need to be up in these
words you know what i mean
completely i have to stop there i'm just
gonna say again congrats
i wish you nothing but the best thank
you so much for talking today thank you
likewise i love your energy too yeah
you're great thank you
thank you